the best way to do it
is to not drop it too
far that way when you go
forward it can count and hold with that
last piece
you might get this drag and then you
have the power of your arms
you then
on the job
[Music]
once you've understood
this feeling
you contradict it completely
drop it right down your back
and do the strike but it's because my
body
is as one
on this one my friend joe
land together
drops on my back my foot and jail land
together
and at least i'm in a sequence
you can in the end
move anywhere because you're part of a
joe
so first i power the joe
then i follow the joker and become part
of the joke
and then i decide oh there's somebody
i need to just let that energy go out
going around about and you go oh i'm
going to go this one
sat next says third third exit off
you go one two three
but you need to be in the flow you know
you don't have to worry about going
what do you say it's natural
so i'd like you to do that now i'd like
you to choose
some different directions